M it's
God it's
God all right all right 2 minute opening
time starts now 45 minutes let's get it
going all right cool cool cool all right
welcome back ladies and gentlemen so we
are discussing whether or not Gentiles
can be saved and obviously I am of the
opinion that biblically speaking of
course Gentiles can be saved the
non-israelites and I'm talking about non
Israelites Gentiles according to the
flesh cap so um as a Christian I believe
that Jesus is not just for the
Israelites but he was for the entire
world the Israelites first then the rest
of the Nations and so that's my position
and that's what we going to be getting
into let's
rock that's your opening yeah just
little all right go ahead you got two
minutes yeah you a tell me to break
everything down yeah he
you want me to bring something down on
that all right um my position on
Gentiles is Gentiles always have context
so he's right when he says um that
Christians believe that Gentiles meaning
non-israelites can be saved my position
is that Gentile um is only any Scripture
that's referring to gentille strangers
Heathen XYZ on the subject of Salvation
is only talking about Israelites
biblically speaking the word Gentile
just means going or Nation so by prox
see Israel would be a nation so they can
be called Gentile you can see that in
Genesis 25 and 23 for example so my
position is just to sh and prove that
the promises of Salvation was only given
to the children of Israel and if I can
add only the children of Israel are the
children of God and that's the only one
that can get the promises or salvation
uh with that I'm ready to rock and roll
all right let's go ahead and kick it off
man um so I guess I'll start it off with
a question just like last time
I like that smirk
man I like the smirk I like the smirk I
know you listen I'mma see you I'm be
like yeah he done learn then I'm going
to be the father you going to be the
son that's good that's good bars bar gu
shout out to my man daners send APR so
okay so when it comes to the they don't
sound they don't got the same effect no
you know I got my own little yeah no I
know you got your own little yeah so
with the with the non-israelites
um you're saying that non-israelites
cannot be saved this salvation is only
for you know Israelites born Israelites
you know Israelites that are that are of
the Seed of Abraham physically yeah
physically okay so how do you interpret
then um I guess Romans 11 obviously it
talks about how the Jews are the natural
branches that were cut off and then the
Wild Olive was drafted in um and how
they're not of isra as a matter of fact
he even starts off with saying now to
you Gentiles I say to you right at first
he was speaking to the Israelites
earlier in the chapter and then now he's
speaking to the Gentiles who were not
the natural branches so I I I would
obviously think that they were
non-israelites
that's what you would think the subject
matter of Romans the 11th chapter is has
God Cast Away his people we agree right
correct and he says God forbid yes then
the ending verse in Revelation excuse me
in verse 26 it says and so all Israel
shall be saved as it is written we agree
right say that again sorry in verse 26
Romans 11:26 it says and so all Israel
shall be saved as it is written we agree
there right yes so how could the subject
be about nine Israelites when in
conclusion of everything that he says
says so all Israel shall be saved
doesn't say all nations shall be saved I
I agree I I don't think that all nations
will be saved because not all nations
will come into Bel but it's it
specifically talks about how the
Israelites were cut off the natural
branches are the Israelites they're cut
off and then so now the wild branches
that are not originally part of the
natural tree are now grafted in now the
Israelites are the natural BR are part
of the natural branches and so the
unnatural ones the Wild Ones obviously
will be non-israelite Gentiles no
because the the most important part the
reason why it's called a wild Olive Tree
is because this tree doesn't look like
all trees because when you first go to
Romans 11 uh before we get to the Wild
Olive Tree I want to start at verse 13
if you don't mind yeah it says for I
speak to you Gentiles in as much as I'm
I'm the Apostle of the Gentiles I
magnify mine office if by any means I
may provoke me provoke to emulation then
which My Flesh and might save some of
them the F the only flesh that Paul has
are Israelites right that's what he says
according to Romans 9 and4 so now when
you go it says I'm going go down to
where you're talking about it says verse
16 for the first fruit be holy then the
lump is Holy and if the root be holy so
are the branches that's right and if the
sum of the branches be broken off and
thou being a wild Olive Tree were
grafted in so that mean that those
branches are being brought back in as
they once were broken off right I'll
give a brief uh precept Jeremiah 11:16
the Lord called by name a green olive
tree fairing goodly fruit with the noise
of a great Tomo Heath kindered fire upon
it and the branches of it are broken
that's how the olive trees got broken
off the branches got broken off of that
olive tree for the Lord of hosts that
planted the tree have pronounced evil
against thee for an evil house so when
you go back to Romans the 11th chapter
that Wild Olive Tree is them being
allowed to be grafted back in okay so uh
just just reading this here so it says
but if some of the branches were broken
off and you although a wild Olive Chute
were grafted in among the others and now
share in the nourishing root of the
Olive Tree do not be arrogant toward the
branches if you are remember it is not
you who support the root but the roots
that supports you then you will say
branches were broken off so that I might
be grafted in that is true they were
broken off because of their unbelief but
you stand fast through faith so do not
become proud but fear for if God did not
spare the natural branches neither will
he spare you so these are not natural
branches they were never part of the
tree in the first place but now they're
being grafted in they're not natural to
the tree that's not true and context and
listening is an art and he never
answered verse 16 it says for the first
fruit behold ho the lump is also holy
and if the root be holy so are the
branches those other branches are never
attached to the root when the branches
get broken off that's why in the in the
metaphor it talks about them being
grafted back into a wild Olive Tree
Jeremiah 11:16 that I just uh uh spoke
about that he did not answer also speaks
about the Lord bringing a fire to that
same Olive
Tree where where does it say that
they're being grafted back in the the
wild
thou will say then I'm sorry um if some
of the branches in verse 17 if some of
the branches are broken off and thou
being a wild Olive Tree the tree is
talking about the first fruit be holy
and the lump that is also holy and the
root that's the tree Y and so then it
says and thou being a wild Olive Tree
were grafted in among them and with them
partakers of the root and fatness of the
Olive Tree boast not against the
branches but if thou boast thou bearest
not the root what this is talking about
is Judah and Israel or if you want to
say northern kingdom and Southern
Kingdom some people say that because
when Christ was on the scene Christ said
I'm not sent but into the lost sheep of
the House of Israel the tribes of Israel
as a nation was not there they were cut
off another excellent example is the
prodigal son when the prodigal son you
had the two sons the two you always
notice it's always in TW because you had
northern kingdom and Southern Kingdom so
the northern kingdom gets kicked out
he's Walling himself in the
and when he comes back to the house and
is accepted of the father who's angry
about that the son that stayed and so
Judah didn't want those son excuse me
didn't want his brother to come back
Isaiah 11:13 is another example when it
says the Envy of Judah and the vexation
of Ephraim shall go away so in verse 26
which is what I asked earlier when it
says and so all Israel shall be saved as
it is written the subject is about
Israel not being Cast Away according to
the first verse verse 13 when it says
I'm 14 rather when it says I provoke the
emulation them which are my flesh that's
found in Romans 9:4 them are my flesh
who are Israelites to whom pertain the
adoption the glory the covenants the
services and the promises so this okay
okay I got you so so when you said I
didn't answer about 16 I I felt like I
did because when I you said that they're
being grafted back in but in this
context it doesn't say that they were
never part of the natural tree to begin
with so that's why I'm saying here when
it says but if you I'm sorry but if some
of the branches were broken off and you
although a wild Olive Sho were grafted
in these people were not broken off of
this tree in the first place they're
bringing they're being grafted into the
tree and now taking part in the
nourishment so you have the natural
branches that were cut off before and
now there's room for the unnatural
branches to be grafted in like when you
when you bring up like you said uh Judah
and who else was it Ephraim uh Ephraim
Israel I think I say Israel Israel so
Judah and and Israel are is Judah and
Israel both part of the natural um tree
until he burned it in Jeremiah 11th
chapter which I just read he separated
he kicked out the whole northern kingdom
he kicked out nine tribes right yeah so
wait so I have a question what did what
did those nine tribes become uh they
became the the other Kingdom no no when
they got kicked out what did they become
what what kind of you're talking about
so in Second Kings the 17th chapter when
he kicked out the northern kingdom and
so they kicked out as a nation so ephra
manessa ishar Gad neali Etc what did
they become when they got kicked out of
Israel I I don't know I don't know
that's the Gentiles that it's talking
about what do it mention that they're
the
Gentiles where does it say they're the
Gentiles okay so let me give you a
prophecy no where does it say they're
the Gentiles that's a the word Gentile
means Nation we agree right yeah but
you're you're saying that no so I'm
saying that the Gentiles biblically are
non-israelites no that's what you're
saying even in the zandan Bible
dictionary it to say Gentiles are
usually non-israelites so where where my
question is where does it call them
where does it identify them as the
Gentiles this context if you listen to
my opening statement Gentile just means
Nation so where are they called the
Gentiles so I'm going break it so I'll
give you an example this is Genesis 48
since you want to know exactly where
that's a different one so no it's right
on the subject okay it's right on the
subject because this is prophecy Genesis
48 when Jacob excuse me when Jacob was
talking or Israel was talking to Joseph
and he blessed Ephraim this is what he
said to Ephraim and his father refused
and said I know it my son I know it he
shall become a people and he shall also
be great but truly his younger brother
which is talking about Ephraim shall be
greater than he and his seed shall
become a multitude of Nations that word
in the Greek or Hebrew excuse me would
be Gentile so now right here we're
reading Jacob or Israel tell Joseph that
his son would become a multitude of
Nations or a multitude of Gentiles so
can you show me what nations did they
become well actually that that ties in
with the Covenant that's given to
Abraham and how he will be a father of
many nations and how is it because the
Bible says that it's through faith that
Abraham was made a father to many that's
not answering my question isites it is
answering your question what nations did
no what nations did they become what
nations did they become they not called
Ephraim so what nations did they become
the church they're believers what nation
did they become they're the church
they're the so y hear this he don't know
the nation right they're the church see
every you can do all this all you want
but you're not to answer you didn't tell
me I'm answering your question I'm
telling you the Gentiles in Romans the
11th chapter Romans the 11th chapter it
says so all Israel shall be saved
because northern kingdom Israelites are
they are they the natural branches is my
was my question they were natural to the
branches were broken off they were were
they broken off according to Jeremiah
the 11th chapter so I got the branch is
broken off yes and this but this is I'm
not see I'm not disagreeing that the
some that the Israelites were broken off
my here's where we disagree here you're
saying that the wild that the wild one
right that's being grafted in you're
saying that they were part of the tree
in the first place but then got broken
off and now they're being brought back
in it doesn't say that it says that they
were it says they were wild and they
were never part of the tree in the first
place that's not what they're saying
that's what you're lying about and say
that's not that's not what it's saying
says because of their dis if it was
about other nations if it was about
other nations it wouldn't say and so all
Israel shall be saved no that's not it
would say all nations shall be saved
this argument is that Nations can be
saved this is this is why I said the
word Gentile always has context so it
says and so all Israel shall be saved as
it is written they shall come out of
Zion the deliverer and shall turn
ungodliness away from Jacob it doesn't
say turning ungodliness away from
everyone well that but that's in that
verse you're you're still you're you're
you're uh quote minding we're talking
I'm not quote minded I'm context minded
but you're not but you're not because
you're going to another verse that has
nothing to do with this right here of
course of course in talking about Jacob
we know that God's going to bring back
Jacob he has a Remnant we already know
about this when it says so I'll go
directly hold on let me land this when
we're talking about here these the the
wild yes the wild branches um U so but
if some of the branches were broken off
talking about the natural branches right
all uh and you although a wild all of
you the Gentiles no that's where we
disagree but it l say I'm speaking to
you Gentiles that's literally how he
starts off EXA look look he says in
verse 13 now I'm speaking to you I'm
saying no no when I'm saying you I'm not
saying that he's not talking to Gentiles
okay the U in verse 17 is talking about
the first fruit and the lump so in verse
16 when it says for if the first fruit
be holy the lump is also holy and if the
root be holy so are the branches the
root is the tree the branches is what's
breaking off the tree right and so now
when it says and if some of the branches
be broken off that same tree that's the
root and then thou being a wild Olive
Tree the thou is that root or that tree
that is now wild because the branches is
broken off the branches are being put
back on the same tree that's why it's
called a wild Olive Tree no you can't
say that it's it's called a wild Olive
Tree if it was part of the natural tree
in the first place it's not wild
that don't even make sense it does make
sense because look here's the
distinction there's two things being C
out here you got the natural and you got
the wild these are the two two
identifiers that we have in Romans 11
that's what you're saying no okay let me
let me see here now I'm speaking to you
Gentiles in as much then as I am an
apostle to the Gentiles I magnify my
Ministry in order somehow to make my
fellow Jews jealous okay what version
are what are you reading right now this
this is uh ESV okay I don't read the ESV
I'm going to read the KJV it's a more
accurate and I'm going to read the same
verse that you read it says now I speak
for I speak to you Gentiles and as much
as I'm the Apostle of the Gentiles I
magnify mine office if by any means I
may provoke to emulation them which are
my flesh and might save some of them so
now if you want to make these Gentiles
be non-israelites who's Paul's flesh in
this verse well so here's my question
like I answered your question I need my
question no you didn't answer you just
gave me another question that's what
question did I answer I'll deal with it
no no I don't want you to deal with it
tell me what question I didn't answer so
the the question that you didn't deal
with was him speaking to the Gentiles
and the distinction he makes with the
wild branch and the natural okay so now
I'm going to respond to that directly
I'm telling you the Gentiles is
Israelites so now I'm answering that
question and I'm telling you that in
verse 16 the the lump and the holy and
the root and the branches are all the
same and in 17 and if some of the
branches are broken off is the same
branch that was broken off according to
Jeremiah the 11th chapter and the thou
being a wild Olive Tree is the root of
verse 16 so now I've clearly answered
your question so now I need my question
answered who is the emulation of them
which are his flesh to Paul okay
according to scripture so these are the
Israelites so now they who they're
Israelites up his flesh right so oh that
that's good y yep yep let's get it let's
get it let's get it so if he's talking
about the Israelites that's the ones he
wants to make jealous correct no that's
the one that he wants to save that's why
you can't read that red ass ESV Romans
11 say this what Romans 11:4 says I'm
using what you just read you just read I
didn't read jealous you said ulation
right jealousy no if I may by any means
provoke the emulation to them that are
my flesh and might save them who are his
flesh I'm glad you said that no no
answer straight up who's the flesh can I
read the scripture it's it's right here
who are Israelites thank you so his
flesh are the Israelites and who he's
talking to he's talking to Israelites no
it says he's talking no all right so now
it's my turn it says that he's talking
to Gentiles no no but I'm what I'm
saying is he's talking to I'll be done
with this so you can understand when I
say Israelites the Gentiles in Romans
the 11th chapter are Israelites so I
don't want you to be confused no I
understand what you're saying but here's
where the the the conflation is when you
say that that the ones that he's uh you
know bringing to emulation and wanting
to save are of his flesh which you said
are the Israelites that means he's
talking to non-israelites about his
brothers so he's saying about the
Israelites to the Gentiles that God in
order to provoke them to jealousy or
emulation so that some of them may be
saved has grafted you non uh
non-israelites into the tree so that
they may be provoked and here's how
that's a
lie here's how that's a lie because when
it comes to save he says and so all
Israel shall be saved the emulation
through what what what's I'm I'm going
right to the emulation the emulation and
save some of them of his flesh they're
rejecting the Israelites in Rome the
whole argument in Rome galatia capid
dohia is that if they could be
Israelites but they ain't circumcised on
the eighth day they can't come back home
so when we go back the reason why I
reference Romans the 9th chapter Romans
the 9th chapter help you understand
Romans the 11th chapter let's read it
Romans 9:4 who are Israelites to whom
pertain the adoption now Ain't No Other
Nation could get adopted now because
this just said Israel pertain the
adoption the glory them first it it
don't say them first it says who are
Israelites to whom pertain the adoption
the glory the covenants the giving of
the law the services of God and the
promises that's what the scriptures say
whose fathers and of whom is concered in
the flesh Christ came now it's saying
Christ came for the Israelites you
finish that verse though I'm which one
verse five yeah yeah I'm going keep no
I'm going keep I'm going to read a
couple more verses if you don't mind
yeah yeah don't who is overall God
blessed forever who's overall who who is
over all who God blessed forever Jesus
Jesus is overall God blessed forever
says for who the fresh Christ came who
is all and God is blessed forever they
ain't saying Jesus Is God that's that's
hor yo come that's
trash god overall man no it's not God is
overall he ain't Christ
the crazy as hell so now verse six says
neither neither as though the word of
God have taken n effect for they are not
all Israel which are of Israel so being
in Israel doesn't make you Israel
meaning living in the land so now that's
not about the land let's keep well let's
keep going to see if I'm right or you're
right let's keep going ver is doesn't
make you is what we about to read
eliminates Every Nation neither because
they are the Seed of Abraham are they
all children but and Isaac shall thy
seed be called verse eight that is they
which are the children of Flesh these
are not the children of God right so
anybody that's the children of the flesh
are not children of God but the children
of the promise accounted for the seed so
[__] moabites jebusites Canaanites
ammonites Israelites none of them are
the children of God according to what we
read okay can I respond to this go ahead
okay cuz now cuz that was a lie what you
just said and I say that respectfully
why you just read this well no you
misinterpreted what you just read now
let me let me now now now it's my turn
let's let's read it correctly now 20
more minutes 20 more
minutes we can probably put some more on
there I knew you want to put some smoke
on the good oh yeah good you know how we
fired up it says but it is not as though
the word of God has failed for not all
who are descended from Israel belong to
Israel so you just read that and you it
written right over your head all who
descend from Israel are not of Israel so
just because you are a descendant of
Israel by in your flesh doesn't make you
of Israel so it shows you it's not of
the flesh it's of God now how so he
continues he says and not all the not
and not all are children of Abraham
because they are his seed you you just
disqualified yourself because you're
saying that you have to be saved as an
Israelite physically an Israelite in
order to take part in the promises and
the Covenant it just said that just
because you are a Seed of Abraham does
not mean you are of Abraham you cut
yourself man so and but you wanted to
read that fast and skip over that let's
keep going it says here it says here so
let me read that part again and not all
the children of Abraham and not all are
children of Abraham because they are of
his seed but through Isaac shall your
Offspring be named this means Paul tells
us what this means this means that it is
not the children of the flesh who are
the children of God so just because you
are Israelites by the flesh does not
mean your children of
God and what and this goes back this
goes this goes to John 1 cuz you said it
eliminates all the nations this goes to
John 1 what it talks about to whoever
believes in his name verse 12 he gave
right to be called sons of God not being
born of man or the flesh but by the will
of
God we just read just read done done I
don't want to be too late done cuz he
just lied like [__] and y'all ate it up
I read what you read and you twisted
this up I did not read it here's what
here's what you read I know you didn't
read it first of all I read the verse
and I said just because you're in Israel
doesn't make you Israel I said that did
I not say that yes or no you're trying
to say in Israel the land not that's
exactly what I'm saying now so now let's
go when it says neither because they are
the Seed of Abraham are they all
children why is that important he want
to clip this debate to 45 minutes cuz he
want to go battle
Arabs I understand he want to run all
right so now but are the Arabs not
Israelites n are they the Arabs Ain
Israelites not them that's debatable but
Arabs in general are they not is are
they sons of Abraham uh yeah some of
them no they not not according to what
we reading because it says neither are
neither because they are the children of
the flesh are they the children excuse
me be I'm sorry neither because they are
the Seed of Abraham are they all
children Ishmael had seven eight excuse
me Abraham had eight Sons okay the
children of the flesh are not the sons
of Abraham so Ishmael and the other five
brothers me other five son me had seven
sons other five sons that he had in
Genesis the 25th chapter are not the
sons or Seed of Abraham that's why it
says but in Isaac shall thy seed be
called I Ain't finished not just now
that is this ain't got nothing to do
with Israel he's eliminating all of the
other sons that Abraham had remember he
said oh that Ishmael might live he gave
that [__] a damn blessing and say keep
it moving that's it but the promise but
the promise
he but the promise but now because this
is important it is that is the children
of the flesh these are not the children
of God but the children of the promise
the promise was only given specific so
let's read who was given the promise for
This Is The Word of Promise at this time
I will come and sah shall have a son and
not only this but when Rebecca also
conceived by one Our Father Isaac for
the children being not yet born neither
having done good or evil but that
according to election might stand not a
works but of him that calleth verse 13
I'm sorry verse 12 it is said unto the
Elder excuse me it was said unto her the
Elder Shall Serve the younger as it is
written Jacob have I loved Esau have I
hated the Lord chose to give the promise
to Jacob not to Esau and so that's who
belongs the promise so the other nations
that you talking about which still can't
answer what other nations did Ephraim
become and so this is what this is what
we are answering so you when you talked
about children of the flesh right
because you're not because the ones who
are born of the flesh are not the
children of God Abraham obviously had
children of the flesh correct they had
he had physical children I had to teach
him well no but you just said that this
isn't talking about Israel but it
literally starts off with just because
you are descendants of Israel does not
make you of Israel the whole wait hold
on context is talking about Israel you
can't separate it it's talking about is
separating okay good so then what what
you need to understand here is that it's
it's making a distinction between you
you being born of the flesh right and
then saying that you are a child of
Abraham because you are related to him
physically uh versus being related to
him because of your faith you are a
child of Abraham because you believed
not because of your uh your how you're
born this is the whole context of this
this is why if you keep reading down in
Romans 9 yeah keep going down we keep
going down don't do it don't do it we
going to do it don't do it we going to
do it go ahead do it go ahead do it do
it so so so this is what it says we keep
going down right in order to make known
The Riches of his glory for vessels of
Mercy which he has prepared beforehand
for Glory uh verse 23 okay all right so
now I know where you're going yeah get
right there get to it even even us whom
he has called not from the Jews only but
from the gentil get the coffin get the
coffin as indeed says in hose those who
were not my people I will call my people
and her who was not beloved I will call
beloved he's not talk Israel was beloved
right was Israel beloved absolutely was
Israel his people absolutely so the
people that's not called his people he's
now calling his people because of Christ
this is this is the whole thing with
this respond I can respond to that hey
did y'all get that c I started to bring
a coffin remember I told you I was going
to bring a coffin we had the body bag
and everything for him now let me tell
yall something remember I told you and I
I'm I'm you know you you close you close
to being a good debator you close now in
Romans 9:24 that he just read he said
even us whom he have called not of the
Jews only but also of the Gentiles
remember I told you the word Gentile
means nation of which Israel is a nation
and you have to look at the context and
when you read the very next verse it
says as he also saith in OC he going to
leave after this y'all as he also saith
in OC I will call them my people which
were not my people and her beloved which
was not my beloved and then he asked me
Israel is his people right I said yeah
Israel is beloved right he said yeah so
he's going to call a people that was not
his people his people and I said yes why
did I say that because if it says as it
also saith in OC you know what you got
to go do got to go to you got to go to
Hosea what did Hosea say let's see what
Hosea said did Hosea say something like
that so now let let's go to Hosea let's
go to Hosea so Hosea said let's go Hosea
1:9 then said God call his name low and
M now for backdrop time say this when
Hosea had Daughters of excuse me took
children of whoredoms and reference to
Israel right so then it says then God
said call Name Lord my for ye are not my
people and I will not be your God so now
here is the Lord cutting off the
children of Israel from being his people
verse 10 yet the number of the children
of Israel shall be as the sand of the
sea which cannot be measured nor
numbered and it shall come to pass in
that place where it was said to them ye
are not my people there he there it
shall be said unto them ye are the sons
of the Living God so what people who is
that talking to who that talking to I
mean who was that said to in what land
in ver in verse 11 it says then shall
the children of Judah and the children
of Israel shall be gathered together and
appointed themselves one head which is
Christ and they shall come up out of the
land so that verse that Paul is quoting
is only talking about Israel so the
Gentiles in that verse is Israel Hey Hey
Hey cap cap cap what land is this cap
what is stand like this for the whole
rest of I bet what what land is this
what land is this that they're coming
out of what you said it said well the
verse says in the pl it shall come to
pass that in the place where was said to
them ye are not my people yeah what
place that's any place what place the
places that they were scattered to oh
time out so in the place that they're
scattered to in these places they're not
called the people of God is that correct
just Paul is going to these Gentiles
these Israelites in Rome he's telling
them that they are the children of God
got you but they're in a land where
people are not called his people this is
the point they're they're now scattered
to where the the the they're in a land
where people are not the people of God
because they're not Israelites and now
they're being called out of that land
and so in the context of Romans 9 he
literally addresses this to Israelites
and says just because you are of Israel
according to the flesh that doesn't make
you of is
that's the whole
point again you keep a prophet a prophet
listen man wait wait question here's my
question okay because you're saying that
you're talking about Nations you think
you're you're identifying Israel as the
Nations the Lord did that the Lord told
ephra he would be Nations you don't know
who they are you already admitted you
don't know who they are no worries so
right do for me go to Isaiah 49 before
we get to Isaiah 49 I don't have a
problem going there I just want to clean
up what you tried to run from I
addressed it directly no you didn't when
I gave you Romans 9:24 and told you OC
and said those the people you tried to
run back up I was in again this prophecy
was fulfilled for the children of Israel
no it's through the Gen it's fulfilled
in the Gen isra it doesn't say Gentiles
are going to be called this people it it
literally says out of the land people
are not called in Hosea 1 and9 the Lord
said Israel would not be his people isut
and then the very next verse it says yet
the number of the children of Israel
shall be as the sand of the sea and
where was said ye are not my people
there ye shall be and so even if you
want to argue even if you wanted to try
to argue that non-israelites would be
able to come back in you have to agree
that Paul is quoting Hosea 1 that's
talking about Israelites being called
back to God AB no so that that's part of
it which is it's not part of it that is
it which is also part of Romans 11 okay
so where's the inclusion of other
nations in Hosea well so this is what
I'm saying here I Ain let you get away
well that's I already answered that
where's the inclusion of other nations
I'm just asking my question I'm going be
quiet okay go ahead where's the
inclusion of other nations in Hosea 1
9-11 I need that answer all right thank
you so when you said that they coming
out of the land by which the people are
not called my people that's where he's
talking about and says they will soon
one day be called his people which is
what Paul does he draws that in Romans 9
draws that in Romans 9 talking about the
Gentiles and not answering my question I
I I directly just I said where in Hosea
1 9- 11 where does it include other
nations no no I a't ask you to reference
it read the verses and tell me where
other nations are in there what you're
what you're doing is is when you when
you read Romans 9 and you took it out of
context I'm putting it in the cont take
it out of context you did because you
said inserted non-israelites in Hosea
one not let me but you inserted that in
there no I I didn't insert nothing I
just me where hose so can you read Hosea
1 9-1 and show me where non Israelites
is in there sure sure no worries so
Hosea 1 9 and 11 and then we're going to
go to Isaiah 49 right because it's going
to show you the nations are are
non-israelites and after this I know you
want to do Isaiah 49 um s after I beat
you out of this one I'll beat you on
Isaiah I'm going lay you down in this
one man so look yet uh verse n and the
Lord said call his name not my call his
name uh not my people for you are not my
people and I am not your God yet the
number of the children of Israel shall
be like the sand of the sea which cannot
be measured or numbered and in the place
where it was said to them you are not my
people it shall be said to them uh
Children of the Living God and the
children of Judah and the children of
Israel shall be gathered together and
they shall appoint for themselves one
head and they shall go up uh go up from
the land for for great shall be the day
of of Jezreel now here's the question
how is how is it this is the answer how
is it that Israel is going to be uh as
numerous as the stars is not by through
the flesh it's through the faith in
Jesus Christ it's but it's question that
is the you asked me how does Hosea talk
about other nations being grafted in
what I'm showing you is is that it gives
you what I said come on come on I said
how and Hosea I but I didn't say that
you just repeated something you asked me
where how you asked me where in Hosea uh
uh 1 9-1 does it talk about Nations
that's what you ask I'm literally
answering to that
literally literally answering to that so
when it says here that Israel will be as
numerous as the stars and will also be C
out of the land from which they were
called not my people in the Gentile
lands and they will be brought out and
after they're brought out they will be
as numerous as the Stars this goes back
to the Covenant that God made with
Abraham that says that you will be as
numerous as the star your descendants
and and Paul says it's not through the
flesh but it's through faith in Jesus
it's because of the faith in the Messiah
that Abraham grew not because of Israel
according to the flesh this is why I'm
talking about the Nations here see
you're trying to say that the nations
are Israelites I want to show you Isaiah
496 that shows that they're not I'm not
I didn't say that the nations are
Israelites that's not what I said I said
the word Nation or Gentile can be
Israelites is is what what he's doing is
called replacement theology no I'm not
what his y are there is no there is no
there is no scripture in here in what no
verse in here in Hosea 1 9-11 that says
that other nations are going to be
joined it clearly says that the children
of Israel are not God's people but
they'll be called God's people and when
you make it not about a fleshly thing in
the same Romans the 9th chapter verse 29
it says and as Isiah said before except
the the Lord of Sabbath had left us a
seed we'd be like Sodom and be made like
unto gomorah so if the seed of Israel
did not matter or let's just let's say
if the seed of Israel but then where are
the other na cuz what you want us to
believe is that what you want us to
believe is that when it said what you
want us to believe is that when it says
in Romans about the children of Rich me
children being called children of God
that this includes non Israelites yeah
you ask me where the nations are coming
from
no I ask you where is other nations in
verses 1 9- 11 and you didn't show that
it only shows by Nation Judah and Israel
that's all it shows so when when Paul
here applies this to the Gentiles he's
not applying it that's replacement
theology he does he says not of the Jews
only but of the Gentiles as well because
you're not an Israelite because you're
descended from Israel the cont I'm
trying to tell you where the nations are
coming from the no that's not true you
are using using you are absolutely using
replacement theology because what you're
saying inclusion theology inclusion
replacement it's not Bible theology it
ain't got nothing to do with the Bible
49 let's go thank you so let's see if
there's inclusion okay so when he says
here about the Messiah right the servant
of the Lord he says it's too great it's
too light a thing that you should be my
servant to raise up the tribes of Jacob
and to bring back the preserved of
Israel who are the tribes of Jacob
Israel Israel who's the preserved of
Israel Israel right and then that would
be the remnant right well my if you're
going to ask me a question why is he
saying Jacob and Israel twice if they
the same Nation well because he he
actually qualifies it he says the 12
tribes of Jacob and the preserved of
Israel who are the
preserved because there's a Remnant that
God always keeps for himself of Israel
there's always but they all Israel right
yeah they're all Israel is that a
pattern in the Bible I will have mercy
on Jacob and yet choose Israel that
ain't got nothing to do with preserve
that's just the way that he talks that
doesn't that's no that doesn't Isaiah
141 Isaiah 14:1 I will have mercy on
Jacob and yet choose Israel is that not
the same Nation so I'm asking you why is
he saying it twice you have to bring
that up but what I'm saying here is is
right here bring it up it's the same
context why is he saying it twice not
the same context I just told you you
have the 12 you have the 12 tribes and
then you have the preserved of Israel
who are the preserved of Israel okay me
personally not I want say me person me
biblically when it say no it's you
personally you was right you was right
no it's not so when it says Isaiah
49 um which verse was it oh say six
right yeah when I would light thing to
raise up the tribes of Jacob and to
restore the preserved of Israel if he
have them reserved he don't have to
restore him they're already reserved to
him the reason why he scatter doesn't
matter they're still reserved to him
Paul makes the same reference in Romans
the 11th chapter more specifically so
now if he has a pattern of saying Jacob
and Israel Jacob and Israel to you I'm
assuming the light to the Gentiles mean
that the Gentiles get to come and join
not not just that my friend but it's
more minutes five more minutes but the
Sal the Salvation is going to them
because look the 12 tribes of Jacob you
said that's Israel yes and then he
mentions The Remnant or the preserved of
Israel that's Israel so Israel is
accounted for in the first in the first
Clause right so then he says but I will
also make your to to the Gentiles or the
Nations and your position is that that's
other nations right that it's non-
Israelites he already abely Israelites
but he just mentioned the Israelites so
if he mentioned all the 12 tribes he
mentioned the preserved of Israel then
next now it's now I will make you a
light to the Gentiles so that my
salvation May reach the ends of the
Earth so let's keep read so let's keep
reading why stop at verse 6 why we can't
keep reading I'm just I'm just asking so
who is that wait I'm going to answer I'm
going to keep reading verse uh seven
thus sayth the Lord um first of all if I
start at no no I I'll do that just for
time sake but I say the Lord the
Redeemer of Israel God damn it just
start off right start
sprink it don't say the Redeemer of
everybody it say the Redeemer of Israel
and the whole this is right the very
next verse he just said he's the
Redeemer of everybody he did not say he
the Redeemer of them the word Gentile
and this is why I ask you them questions
you can't say who the other uh Ephraim
became even though the Lord said Ephraim
would become many Gentiles get away from
this how what you mean by how how why
don't you tell me how see see can you
tell me who the nations are the answer
is right here can you tell me who the
nations are rest of the world and also
by Hosea 1 when he said you going to not
be my people that's how and so Paul went
there to be the light to the Gentiles
based on them not being his people in
Hosea 1 based on Genesis 48 that we read
where ephan was told he was going to be
many nations what did that mean ephan
was going to get scattered and be called
by many different nations so the reason
why Hosea I excuse me Isaiah 49 says a
light to the Gentiles because that's
what we are today when we go wake up
Israelites the very next verse in verse
S says thus sayith the Lord the Redeemer
of Israel and His Holy One to whom man
despiseth so now if the other nations
despise Israel which the Lord is
acknowledging why would he save them he
says to whom the nations of whth now the
Nations hate Israel to Servants of
rulers Kings shall see arise princes
also shall worship because the Lord that
is faithful and the Holy One of Israel
shall choose thee he's not choosing
other nations he is and so let me let me
just break down what you just read
Because minutes minutes so so not every
nation is against Israel not all the
nations and the Gentiles are against
Isel to Psalms 83 every nation is
against Israel well no because what you
have here you have Nations that are now
coming into the in belief no the Messiah
yes he he literally just said here the
12 tribes of Jacob I make you it's too e
your position but you just said no you
said some nations are not Psalms 83 said
the nations are Confederate against
Israel not all of them no yeah so look
right here says here hold on let me
right here it says here he says it's too
light a thing it's too easy man to save
Israel easy to isra save Israel to save
it's too easy let it let me it's too
easy for me to make you a light uh a
light to
to bring I'm sorry let me just read it
uh to be a light to uh my servant to
raise up the tribes of Jacob and to
bring back the preserved of Israel it's
too easy for me to do that for you so
what I'm Al what I'm also going to do to
show you that I am God is I'm also going
to bring Salvation to the rest of the
world because I didn't call them first
it's too easy so what he's showing you
he's doing something different and more
than what he did in the past in the past
he worked with just Israel and now he's
going to expand it to the rest of the
world that's what he does see Israel is
already accounted for 12 tribes you said
that's Israel the preserved of Israel
you said That's you did say that's
Israel all right I said it's all isra
wait can I respond to that respond in
the two minutes and then two minutes
okay okay the very next verse says that
man despise Israel the nation of [__]
Israel the servants and rulers and Kings
going to see Israel rise princes are
going to worship because the Lord is
faithful and he Holy One of Israel shall
choose thee so if that's what the very
next verse says you can't make the
Gentiles there I'm going go right into
my 2 minutes that's cool do you want to
go last or you want no go you want me to
go first yeah it's okay see you want
last last time okay well you can go
first this time I'll end it right there
minutes go ahead this a closing cuz he
got to run to the Arabs and [__] they
they easier than me they easier than
me all right man so guys just to wrap
this up man we did two debates here and
let's give it up for uh everybody that
participated man um I mean this in all
genu uh this was fun I had a good time
with you cap for real um and uh man you
know you sharpen me today for real so I
appreciate that um yeah yeah you know
hey you know humility man you know you
know yeah exactly so so just to close
off guys what we what we got to is we
saw according to uh according to Paul
both in Romans 9 and in Romans 11 we saw
that salvation goes not just to the Jews
but also to the gentil
and so what the Hebrew Israelites have
to do here is they have to also say that
the Gentiles are also the Israelites
everybody they're all is you Israelite
you Israelite you know you Israelite you
know but but but this is crazy because
in the context and I was surprised that
he went to Romans 9 it literally told us
that you're not of Israel just because
you're born of Israel You're Not the
Seed of Abraham just because you come
from Abraham but it's by faith that you
are a Seed of Abraham you are a Jew
Accord Romans 2 you are Jew inwardly not
outwardly you are circumcised inwardly
not outwardly that's that's Romans
Chapter 2 we in Romans we should have
brought that up we had more time we
would have went through it but what we
see here is we have Isaiah 49:6 that
also deals with this directly it names
off Israel all together the 12 tribes of
Jacob and the preserved of Israel but I
will also make you a light to the
Gentiles these are non-israelites now so
that my salvation May reach just Israel
no so that my salvation May reach the
ends of the Earth not because Israel
scattered everywhere but because there's
Nations that are everywhere that are
going to come into the belief of the
Messiah through his work and they're
calling him Lord of lords King of Kings
because he not just saved Israel but he
saved the Gentiles as well amen yes you
[Applause]
Bo hey I realize now I realize now why
he running cuz and if we would have did
this battle first he wouldn't even
stayed for the second round he'd have
been running in the last verse in Isaiah
49-26 says I will feed them that oppress
thee with their own flesh they shall be
drunken with their own blood as with
sweet wine and All Flesh shall know they
say all flesh didn't say some flesh it
says All Flesh shall know that I am the
Lord and thy Savior and the Redeemer the
mighty one of Jacob you notice it
doesn't have to say all of them because
if you see Jacob if you see Israel in
some context if you see Gentiles it's
the same exact thing so what we learn
here before I go into it first give all
of y'all a hand I appreciate y'all
coming out first time meeting the
brother it was a beautiful build
especially for two brothers I've never
engaged with him at all and so for us to
engag this way is definitely respectful
I give you prop you know what I'm saying
um with that said I whipped his ass I
just got to throw that
out so but what we prove today what we
Jesus can I get hey can I get can I get
it out can I get it out I know it hurt
why y'all a do that for him why y' do
that for him
anyway so anyway when it come to this
subject of Gentile and I hope y'all go
back and listen Genesis 48 and 18 if it
tells Ephraim he's going to become
Nations if Hosea clearly says they're
not going to be the children of God
they're going to be called the children
of God do not fall for replacement
theology you can't be a spiritual Asian
you can't be a spiritual nothing so you
can't make Israel just go away because
you want to not be a Israelite for all y
blacks Hispanics and Native India
especially y y'all you
tyo yeah how Dominican how you not going
to be a Israelite anyway y'all would be
better off being an Israelite because
when judgment comes it's a wrap but I
appreciate y'all rocking with us man
until next time
[Music]
Shalom we got
together oh my God logic
[Music]